we are now talking about Trump perjury
Trump reportedly lying many times during
a completely unhinged deposition which
we have some of the trans transcripts of
and the full transcript is yet to be
released but apparently will be Newsweek
reporting Donald Trump may have severely
damaged his case in the defamation
lawsuit brought against him by a woman
who accused him of rape by expressing
quote repeated lies during his
deposition according to an attorney
Katie Fang who's a legal analyst in
MSNBC host was reacting to the unsealed
transcripts of testimony Trump gave this
is the E Gene Carroll lawsuit Carol
accused Trump of raping her in the mid
90s Trump denies it Carol is now suing
Trump for defaming her character
including stating in a 2019 interview he
wouldn't have raped her because she is
not his type which is
an absolutely insane thing to say Trump
later repeated the same remark on Troth
Central in October of 2022. trough
Central right before the deposition took
place
during his testimony which was unsealed
Monday Trump defended is not my type
remarks while calling the rape claim a
hoax and calling the accuser a whack job
and a liar
um Fang said the legal significance is
Trump steps in it over and over again
and more importantly he basically denies
flat out he's ever touched a woman and
any part of her body specifically is
denying touching a woman on the breast
or buttocks or any other sexual part
without her consent
he said no under oath the whole world
knows that on an Access Hollywood tape
he boasted about how he would grab them
by the blank and you can do it when
you're a star he's caught in repeated
lies throughout the course of his sworn
videotaped a deposition there is now a
bunch of the transcript and it is wacky
you can just imagine Trump talking about
this he was asked you say she completely
made up a story that I met her at the
doors of this crowded New York City
Department Store and within minutes
swooned her do you see that Trump says
yeah
what does swooned her mean Trump that
would be a word may be accurate or not
having to do with talking to her and
talking to her to do an act that she
said happened which didn't happen and
it's a nicer word than the word that
starts with an f and this would be a
word that I use because I thought it
would be inappropriate to use the other
word and it didn't happen
anybody know what he's talking about the
question that follows okay I was curious
when I read this so I looked up the word
swoon in the dictionary and under the
dictionary it means to faint with
extreme emotion that's not what you
meant here Trump says well sort of
that's what she said I did to her She
fainted with great emotion she actually
indicated that she loved okay she loved
it until commercial break in fact I
think she said it was sexy didn't she
she said it was very sexy to be raped
didn't she say that
so sir I just want to confirm it's your
testimony that e Gene Carroll said she
loved being sexually assaulted by you
Trump says well based on her interview
with Anderson Cooper I believe that's
what took place and we could Define that
you'll have to show that I'm sure you're
going to show that but she was
interviewed by Anderson Cooper and I
think she said rape was sexy which it's
not by the way Trump clarifies
um
I hope we at some point get video of
this deposition because it is absolutely
and completely insane but importantly
lying during a deposition can have very
serious legal consequences including
perjury charges perjury is a criminal
offense it can result in imprisonment it
can result in fines but of course
remember
proving perjury is very difficult this
is why I mean listen you and I know
people lie all the time under oath in
court they say things that aren't true
and many of them know that the things
they're saying are untrue but why don't
you often see perjury charges because in
order to get a perjury charge to stick
you have to demonstrate that the person
knew what they were saying was untrue
rather than it was the result of a
mistake in recollection or a lack of
recollection or whatever the case may be
very very difficult the other issue with
lying during a deposition is that you
can be held in contempt
this is all so unlikely to happen to
Trump but it is again more of Trump's
dishonesty more of Trump's inability to
just shut his mouth and
um answer very directly only what is
being asked and lawyers are now saying
many many lies here and it is perjury
what is ultimately going to happen with
the EG and Carol lawsuit we don't know
understand that we now have
the federal investigation into Trump
the New York investigation into Trump
the Georgia investigation into Trump
wearing a grand jury recently finished
its work and we're waiting could be any
day we find out whether Trump is going
to be charged there uh we have this
lawsuit we have the cases against
Trump's organization I'm sure I'm not
even covering all of it and the next
thing involves Rudy Giuliani including
Rudy's claim that Trump told him hey
Rudy take some of these top secret files
to your house let's talk talk about that
next did you know that half of Americans
are deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman the link
is down below